while we were in quarantine dobby came
in here and he made one big giant nest
i'm up to my neck and jank right now
we can't cut a hole
in a sheetrock wall
as usual mr paranoid is here yeah come
on in this is great not a [ __ ] glove
not a [ __ ] mess and less than five
feet i gotta show my wife
wait what hold up no no don't do that
you know something i never thought i'd
say this but i love seeing you guys here
i am here today because nico has after
all of these years moved out of the
space on the other side of that wall i
think that was around february of uh
2009 because i'm returning his security
deposit which i have right here
those are the same dollars
that nico gave
steve you better believe that wait a
second hold on
i think i need a cut of it
something believe it or not
i said the same thing this morning when
i wrote the check
he's gonna suddenly go wait a
minute that [ __ ] deposit was mine
that's why i'm here is to do a walk
through with mr
pierringer perringer okay and to
negotiate an expansion of corridor
digital cordo digital just won't be here
anymore it'll be here and all of there
[Music]
the lights are on
the fan is on
oh my god
dude i thought you were steve dude i
thought you were in texas i was i got in
on sunday while we were in quarantine
dobby came in here and he made one big
giant nest i'm up to my neck and jank
right now oh now summer is supposed to
be the boom times it's supposed to be
the times where kids are home from
school they're watching our videos ad
rates are up and god only knows what's
gonna happen this year
step into my office your office yeah
this is a mess in here four days making
this diagram lays out all the problems
that we're facing going into summer it's
all here you know how you get rid of a
nest you burn it no no you pull each one
of the twigs out because if you burn it
you might end up burning everything else
around it and you don't want to burn
those little beautiful baby chicks
first problem we gotta move into studio
three this is something we've been
working on for a long time in addition
to that i heard jan's hardware just
completely crashed out on him yesterday
clint's working on this domino's video
that's like super high level visual
effects and in the midst of all this
we're trying to get everyone back into
the studio which is a total mess by the
way we got this brand integration coming
where ren's gonna do this cool thing
with another 360 drone i heard there's
rats in the studio and on top of all
this steve's coming by and i need to get
ready all the changes that i want to
make to this studio so that it's an easy
pitch to him when he gets in later this
afternoon
studio is indeed a mess we've been out
of it for three months now a lot of
people took some gear home so they could
work from home and you know we weren't
here to kind of keep the everyday
organization going so with the future
expansion we'll be moving a lot of this
stuff so it's like nice to get organized
prior to that so then we move into the
new space and we'll have this easy to
use organization system within the
office here we are in motion we're back
and we're we're making it happen it's my
second week here working at corridor
well actually it's not really my second
week i started during the quarantine but
i started from home so now that we're
actually here in the studio jake tasked
me with organizing
these men's toys airsoft guns nerf guns
bullets props but that's the thing too i
don't know which trash either like
something would literally look
disgusting and they're like oh no that
gets so important we use it in every
video i'm like for sure well the first
time i came to the studio i was like oh
man like this is so cool i'm like taking
pictures of like all like the guns and
stuff and then now that i'm actually
tasked with like labeling everything i'm
like
i'm just gonna i'm gonna make their
lives a little easier and mine as well
and i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna learn
a lot in here i called a nintendo switch
at twitch yesterday so that's where i am
now one of the problems that we face
with the current setup in studio four is
that we have production and
post-production happening right next to
each other and that's a problem because
when you're working on post-production
you need train of thought and you need
your tool your machine to work in real
time with your thought process this is
this is absolutely critical
to the creative process so what we're
going to do up here is a nice
air-conditioned quiet post-production
space when it comes to renovation we're
putting a new electrical new ethernet
we're painting we're doing ceiling fans
doing led lighting we're doing the
floors all that good stuff this is where
most of the
heavier
construction and renovation is gonna
happen this whole half of the studio is
literally like a kill house qcb freaking
airsoft so there's three rooms here i'd
like this one to actually remain a
bedroom when i'm in from san antonio or
when we have people guests come in i
want a nice place for people to be able
to stay comfortably it'll have air
conditioning it'll have lighting all
that good stuff one thing you might
notice is that these are just these
these like unfinished almost partition
walls the guys built them back in the
day they were just looking to do
something quick it was not i don't think
intended to be like a 10-year solution
so these partitions are going to go all
the way up so this room and the next
room over i want to turn into an office
seal this off cut this wall this will be
like a little executive office with also
like a little meeting room to access a
studio that's literally on the other
side of this wall there's been a secret
door behind this bridge the whole time
maybe we'll just not the whole fridge on
a hinge yeah can we just like
through the back of the fridge so we go
through you cut the hole and we'll just
go through the other side and you go
into uh john malkovich's head
so you'll come through here and then
this wall
is just it's just
renovations we have to do up here as
well as some of the smaller things we
need to do in studio for i'm trying to
get this done for
under forty thousand dollars
well we'll see that's enough to do
everything i think and make it a good
comfortable working space for everybody
and now at corridor okay since we've
been back in the studio i realized that
there's another problem that we're all
facing here our internet here is
entirely unencrypted it's adobe snack
and dobie has been living off of these
well guess what thanks to today's
sponsor expressvpn we're going to starve
them out forever did you guys really
think there wouldn't be a brand
integration in my video come on dean i
need you to stop what you're doing right
now okay all the information that you're
sending back and forth across the
network right now is unencrypted
yeah
yeah because here's what we need to do
okay
oh thank you
we need to install expressvpn on every
computer it will encrypt all of our
internet information and we'll be safe
and secure we're gonna starve dobie out
once and forever i yanked rand's uh
computer as well unplug the network dean
go i actually already got expressvpn
using our cord our coupon well you're
gonna have to get it again
install expressvpn right hold my
internet do you realize that expressvpn
has the best current encryption services
available well then we need to get them
on my computer immediately connected
okay don't use current location trick
the internet they have servers in over
94 countries hey did you know that
expressvpn gives you content unblocking
meaning that you can watch content in
other countries here in america
what's your favorite show if you can't
watch it right now it means that you
need to get content on blocking this
happens a lot sorry
nico go to expressvpn.com corridor crew
to find out how you can get three months
free that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
corridor crew e-r-e-n now now
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v
corridor crew
all right e-x
i installed expressvpn on every computer
and now we don't have to worry about a
thing how many days has it been since
you slept
another problem solved around here good
luck with that one dobie it's going to
take you billions of years to unencrypt
that information
the node computer gave us some of the
most interesting problems it crashed in
the most beautiful of ways it actually
was like a piece of art i totally forgot
to get a picture but i've been trying to
describe what i saw because i've never
seen that sort of computer error before
ever what is this i assumed it was some
sort of like graphics card driver error
or something and he got this photo
literally like three seconds before the
computer
totally crashed went to black currently
i'm going to be editing the last of this
medieval ttt on a bundle of wood and the
collective hopes and prayers of everyone
in this room then nico's computer is
connected to dean's
internet uh because there are only so
many pipes we have of good
good fast-moving internet it's adobe man
dobie like smeared bloody poop all over
your notebook hear the rat story all
right backstory when i first got in from
quarantine into the studio i found on my
notepad next to my desk
not just rat poop
bloody smears
like wait griffin
my brother gave me a bag of those
sugar-free gummy bears that um
are like laxatives for a gag gift for
christmas so i've been keeping them on
my desk just as like a you know like
look how funny this is looking poop and
today i found them and there was like a
big hole in them and there was like half
of them are gone
oh no poop candy dude that would explain
it i think the rat ate half of griffin's
poop gummy bears and then well you know
the rest
so this is where i work now
jake
[Music]
hey steve it's a beautiful day
to die to die i like your mask though
when i'm walking down the street in echo
park people go off the sidewalk and they
avoid me at all costs because your mask
well when you see a naked person walking
down the street with a mask like this on
you kind of want to avoid it
the building inspectors came by about
two years ago and they said hey steve we
haven't checked out your building in 35
years it's time to take a look
apparently none of the stuff that was on
the original plans was on the plans as
they stood so he had to have the entire
building looked at all the city
departments had to go through and
approve everything that's now on the
plans
we can't
cut a
hole in a sheetrock wall
you physically can cut a hole in any
sheetrock yes physically can the city of
la and all of its infinite wisdom will
not allow us to remove a sheetrock wall
that we put up
can't do
you can't remove an existing
sheetrock wall that's on an approved set
of plans see this is
as a as a human being and as a landlord
my
biggest concern is safety they only
require you to put one fire extinguisher
in every studio i put three so i do i do
whatever the heck they want me to do and
you even joked a couple years ago when
fire department was killing me you said
when do we have to wear our fire
retardant suits to the building
that joke wasn't that far off because
that's how it felt going through the
that's another department by the way
city planning city zoning handicap
division earthquake division building
and safety the fire department that's
seven electrical even if you're not
doing electrical or plumbing you still
have to go through it just for them to
go like this
oh okay
no changes
so you have to do that multiple times
over with each department the day is
gone
by the way the city plan checker that i
had he was a nice guy he was a very hard
guy a tough guy he was and he said this
to me while i was he said i am
prejudiced against brick buildings i
don't like brick buildings if i had my
way i would have all brick buildings
torn down so i was with my daughter in
santa monica once and we were at a
restaurant at a restaurant that was made
of brick santa monica had some kind of
like a little earthquake and quite a
number of the bricks started falling
down in the restaurant we all had to
vacate the restaurant and yada yada and
i said okay i've legally gone in this
building through two retrofits and the
guy looked at me and he said i don't
care it's still brick
what could i do there's your answer you
were wondering why they came after you
so hard there's your answer dude you had
a brickist on your hands yeah
every brick one one less brick one more
life one less brick
so here's what corridor may do corridor
may put a space here that's 36 inches
and 36 inches wide like for a set of
double doors and it would go up to here
80 inches by 36 and 36 okay so that
would feed right into this room then
then do the same thing here okay so
you'd have a semi-partitioned
area yeah it's really three rooms kind
of
janked together
personally
i don't even care
once those are on a series of plans it
in going through this city this
particular city and what they make you
go through it wasn't even this kind of a
nightmare in 1981 in 82 when we when
john and i went through this so
yeah
well
it does suck to have my dreams shattered
by the cold reality that is bureaucracy
but that's just sometimes the way that
the wind blows and you know what this
means it means that it's an opportunity
to readjust some of our ideas go back
and go through the process of getting
this done right now that's going to take
a while but in the meantime there's
plenty of other things that can get
solved right here right now okay so
jordan's been doing a lot around here
but reorganizing the costume room is
almost like a rite of passage at this
point we've had a few people come in and
do it and i want to see how what she did
stands up to the others did you know
that uh like it's a rite of passage
around here did anyone tell you that yet
no
yeah i think well you did it one time
christian's done it brett did it so we
have to see who's done it the best first
impressions uh pretty good a good sign
that you've taken the time to do it
correctly is the new labels
the new labels is key for me in my
closet i want to be able to see
everything i don't want to have to move
boxes to find things so if you can tell
you can kind of almost see every label
so even like the one back there
prisoners and jumpsuits you know you can
see it you don't have to go digging even
these up here you don't even have to
look inside of it to know what's in
there best attachments pouch best
attachments yeah there's so many
attachments
well i think you've done a great job i
think it is very competitive with the
other versions of this that we've seen
good luck with the prop room that is the
real challenge
as you can see we're doing a ton around
here to fight off dobie and one of the
things that we did is introduce this
mocap pattern on a brand new all
original quarter digital
[Music]
hoodie only is this hoodie one of the
most comfortable hoodies you're gonna
wear it's also got really cool hardware
it's got hidden pockets for whatever you
might need and it's adobe resistant this
sweatshirt also comes in crewneck and i
know that we ran out well guess what we
restocked them and uh what else do we
got oh yeah
jake those are my pants yeah well now
they can be your pants because we
restocked the spectrum reflective
joggers after overwhelming demand
hopefully this stuff won't be gone by
the time i tell you about it because we
tell our website subscribers first uh
they also get 15 off so if you guys want
that go on over to quarterdigital.com
and sign up uh or not go recorder
digital.store and uh get whatever's left
a guy in germany one night came up to me
and he said do you know what your name
means and i said you see mayor i said i
think c is like z-e-e you know the
pacific ocean and mayor and he said no
your last name means
dried bull's penis
i went you know i have not had enough
beers